les bombes sont tombées en pleine nuit
il ne reste pratiquement rien de cet
entrepôt qui servait de prison à des
centaines de réfugiés africains
le bombardement a mis fin à des vies
devenus des cauchemars nous sommes 500
ici dit il dont 120 femmes et 20 enfants
nous souffrons sans eau sans nourriture
la vidéo a été envoyée à cette
journaliste de la chaîne britannique
channel four qui a enquêté pendant des
mois sur les violences dans ces centres
de détention les conditions de vie sont
horribles dit elle les gens boivent
l'eau des toilettes pour survivre
s'allier 2 n'a reçu plusieurs photos
vidéos et témoignages qui raconte
comment les migrants sont battus
torturés vendues et revendues n'hésitent
pas à tirer sur ses érythréens qui
protestent parce que des amis viennent
d'être revendu les images de torture
prises par les bourreaux eux mêmes sont
insoutenables
pendant qu'on torture des adolescents on
appelle leurs parents pour les forcer à
payer une rançon
plus de 5000 africains sont prisonniers
dans ces centres en violation de
plusieurs droits fondamentaux des pères
et des mères de famille qui ont quitté
la violence et la pauvreté à la
recherche d'une vie meilleure
la moitié a été intercepté par les garde
côtes libyens en tentant d'atteindre
l'italie par la mer la communauté
européenne donne 600 millions d'euros
par année à la libye pour qu'elle
empêche les africains de migrer vers le
nord et pour que les garde dans ses
centres il faut mettre fin au débat
politique toxique dit il que les
politiciens arrêtent d'exploiter
l'immigrant comme trophy électorale il
faut en faire une crise humanitaire
prioritaire en attendant ces centres
sont devenus des mouroirs pour des
milliers d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
quand ils ne sont pas bombardé il meurt
de soif de faim de maladies et de
blessures non soigner beaucoup de
maladies dit-elle de tuberculose en
particulier les rares ong présentes en
libye ont à nouveau réclamé l'évacuation
de ses centres en avril dernier quand
des rebelles ont commencé à bombarder
tripoli pour tenter de renverser le
gouvernement d'union nationale
ces rebelles sont dirigé par le maréchal
khalifa haftar qui avait contribué à
faire tomber muamar kadhafi avec les
déliés comme la france et le canada
depuis la libye est un pays en
déliquescence
l'onu parle aujourd'hui de crimes de
guerre les survivants fouillent les
décombres à la recherche d'un souvenir
d'une couverture d'une bouteille tout ce
qui peut être utile pour survivre
reprendre le chemin de la migration
car malgré les murs les prisons les
bombes et les cadavres rien ne semble
arrêter un père ou une mère de tout
faire y compris risqué sa vie pour
offrir à son enfant une vie digne de ce
nom
ici sophie langlois radio canada
montréal